buongiorno ragazzi e benvenuti alla
nuova puntata di cucina buttata che cosa
faremo una lasagna classica alla
bolognese in pochissimo tempo e
gustosissima andiamo a presentare gli
ingredienti per fare la lasagna raboso
niente per fare lasagne alla bolognese
avremo bisogno di 100 grammi di farina
00 un litro di latte 100 g di burro una
cipolla piccola una nota e mezza due
coste di sedano tritato io ne avete
meglio è passato di pomodoro un bel
bicchiere di vino per sfumare mozzarella
volontà ed infine le nostre lasagne e a
nessuno gente momenti ragazzini siamo
quindi subito dal rac 1 mettiamo sopra
perché quello fra un po di tempo per
cuocersi 15 ma andiamo avanti le cotture
più lette
facciamo un bel trito di sedano carote
cipolle prendiamo una bella casseruola
che guidiamo non so dove tiene duro
reese brighi questa mi piace olio
abbondante non so se vi siete resi conto
che non vi ho dato delle dosi specifiche
noi abbiamo hai scritto andiamo col
cuore perché la cucina così col cuore è
allora se parete i quali non possono
esserci anche all'interno di questa cosa
posso fare un sorso si sono un po stanco
vorremmo il cioccolato come cioccolato
stiamo facendo la lasagna prendiamo
questo bel tailleur e sudicio ma c'è un
altro tagliere compagne rino tagliare
non solo abbiamo un pelapatate cui
vorrei pulire le verdure con un
pelapatate penso io
tema che assegna che lo si è letto 10
secondi mentre guglielmo il nostro su
chef chip ed era a tutte le situazioni
qua io andrò a preparare la besciamella
riscaldiamo il latte noi lo facciamo al
microonde con voi potete utilizzare un
altro pentolino noi non abbiamo tutti
questi ventolini omogenea ii chiamava
chiediamo a vedere che cosa fate cui gli
elmi come si deve e fa un lavoro meglio
delle ater e io non penso sono unito il
latte è diventato a temperatura ambiente
la mettiamo nella pentola che perché non
abbiamo spazio non per altro 100 g di
burro guardare rischi
accendiamo la fiamma ma cosa che
bregolato e burro e stupendo
si dà una soddisfazione di autorità
intanto il sedano lo vado a mettere una
padella andiamo a serire 100 g di farina
all'interno del burro e andremo a creare
il famoso rock e chiamano i francesi ma
adesso andremo a colorare la nostra
farina il nostro rua pena diventerà
leggermente bronzeo andremo ad
aggiungere il latte
il problema è che guglielmo non mi ha
dato la punta quindi adesso con questa
cosa verrà tutta lumos ancora sta
trattando la cipolla
invece lui ha fatto un minuto della
terni gronde ha buttato gli ingredienti
già pesanti dal vento che inizia adesso
arrivare cercatemi capire cosa ha fatto
un tempo silenzio il lavoro a questo
punto prendiamo il latte o molto
delicatamente all'interno dell'asl
nel frattempo qui il nostro guglielmo ci
troverà la bellissima noce moscata
sì subito share non prendete questa
balorda come c'era lui prendete la vera
noce moscata che dovete trattare al
momento poi abbondante guglielmo le
attività the troppo grossolane queste
cose cercate di avere una mano un po più
fina delicati ma non era meglio avere un
p merla cosa che three tasse anche o
anche un cuoco domestico comporti cui
hanno lasciato la besciamella attaccare
questo italiana cosa fa sbocciare di
polla lo vedete come si stanno
coccolando fra di loro tra molto come
andremo inserire dentro il nostro
tritato faremo continuare quindi a
immaginare la nostra bresciana punto
come senti io non devo pensare e amo
questa cosa anche perché non le facoltà
per farlo vabbè andiamo
diciamola vogliamo spegnere la stiamo
lasciando un po più lenti na perché ci
vorrà tempo prima che la compone amo ed
entrato alla famiglia spendiamo la via
ma adesso è la lasciamo andare ma ti
senti più sollevato dalle tue
responsabilità oggi non mi do il co
strumento sono ibiza con la destra
faremo una lasagna veloce perché ci
abbiamo fame questo si attacca gli
sconti che un box non si smette mai di
imparare non sapevo
ma se asciugare molto la carne ma
facciamo quasi attaccare perché voglio
andremo a sfumare colpito rio da modella
romana maria è a questo punto ragazzi
andiamo inserire dentro la nostra
passata di pomodoro ovviamente questo è
un consiglio del nostro chef bruno
barbieri ci andrebbero goccino di latte
all'interno del ragù classico alla
bolognese da lui diciamo che non
accettiamo nessun consiglio perché
ovviamente siamo sopra cioè se vuole
prendere una stella anche venire qui in
studio erano federale verde scusa
prendiamo su un goccio di latte
lo so che un social non dovrebbe farlo
ai a posto aggiungiamo un pizzico di
sale
visto che ci vogliamo sbrigare a
mangiare questa lasagna che cosa faremo
noi andremo a dare una precotta alla
nostra pasta mettiamo un pentolino
facciamo bollire l'acqua che noi faremo
un bagnetto a questo in modo tale che si
ammorbidiscono e andremo poi a comporre
la nostra lasagna all'interno del forno
così dobbiamo stare molto meno tempo ad
aspettare
ho preso questa padella faccio bollire
l'acqua ti chiedo di q bettare le
mozzarelle mentre io mentre tu salvi il
mondo io se andiamo a divertire con
queste belle gatte sfoglia e facciamo un
agricoltura ora giustamente non tema
mangiare da guglielmo veramente ci mai
veramente questo sta mangiando tutto
prima facciamo mai visto nemmeno di
farne una un'area metto tre alla volta
strati di passatempo starci bene non mi
piace come la mcqueen una mano vita
differente besciamella cospargerla
arrivare agli angoli costarella notevole
passarella notevole a giro d'olio non
sorella anche qui a pioggia filo d'olio
pure qui poi pronto soccorso alla pasta
del bio loria ultimo strato quando
succedono queste cose play my jam ancora
così
che bello
cosicché interessante imbecilli fidavo
molto molto più lenti nel preparare
questa cosa siamo in due
siamo una squadra siamo fratelli ne dite
di mettere due fiocchi di burro sopra
kennedy deve mettere un like a questo
video se siete reale fino a qui non
viene ancora messa laica questo video o
siete delle brutte persone
ho messo un po troppo avanti così la
cucina è diventata fonte di stress per
il sottoscritto un tempo era divertente
ha invece che mettermi in gioco e subire
critiche parmigiano per fare magari una
piccola crosticina adesso è un ottimo
lavoro gianluigi debuttato al litro
d'olio a concludere tetti di burro
rimetterci leggeri proprio commettiamo
forno a 180
dentro 10 meno di un quarto d'ora e
dovremmo essere fare con le gambe con le
mani del tempo non fermarti fino a
domani per niente la strada maledetta
fuori quello che hai ai bambini arrivano
su quello giusto dargli una mano se poi
ok lo chef ha detto che bisogna attivare
il grill sopra e quindi spostare un
pochino sopra la lasagna quasi tutta
sollevata di bella ok quindi quanto
mette un occhio appena vedete sopra la
crosticina è tutto la vedete venire bene
ragazzi senza gugliemo andiamo a tirare
fuori dal forno questa bellissima
lasagna
la dobbiamo far riposare ovviamente
prima di mangiarla perché sennò rischio
magari di cedere al suo studio
mamma mia ragazzi bella un tè vissuta
come piace a noi una mezz'oretta non la
mangiamo come la mezz'oretta io dico
mezz'ora la tagliamo adesso studiato in
faccia risparmio la fetta di graziano
razziate che la centrale a questa è la
mia no caro navali sotto bisogno abbiamo
vicino tv gianluigi tu vuoi io prendo un
angolo perché sono un gentiluomo si
arrivando a una bella fetta di martino
il nostro video makers diciamo tutti
quattro ragazzi iscrivetevi a questo
canale online cattiva della campana le
notifiche via un pochino se la lasagna
di gianluigi e punk assenti nel mondo
pronti
sei stato bravissimo gianni dire se sarà
sangiorgi più valico di tua madre farò
molto sincero
mammamia moxon e due sono me quella di
mia madre rimane un filino superiore a
si sentono forse i prezzi delle verdure
sono un po troppo grande troppo
grossolano ragazzo eccezionale veramente
bravi oana promossa tutta la vita saluta
saluta junmin ciao ragazzi otto e mezzo
il mio voto e 8 o così tanto come chi
non altro 98 e mezzo 8 vedrà che sono
dato fetecchie 9 bene un successo
ragazzi ci vediamo giovedì con altro
video alle 14 ciao
le iscrizioni degli addetti relight ciao